the federal reserve it seems like they
are in control they are the driver of
good times they're the driver of bad
times and everything is one trade if the
fed says we're gonna pump liquidity get
long and shut up and let them just do
their thing if they say they're going to
pull the liquidity away basically get
out of the market it seems like is that
a fair categorization of what the fed's
role in financial markets is today
they're not in control of anything but
certainly in the short run the markets
trade off of the fed and what they
believe the fed is going to do
and i think the fed still has a large
degree of credibility why i have no idea
maybe because the people following the
fed are just as clueless as the fed so
when the blind you know is leading the
blind you know the blind that are
following along you know have no idea
that they're following somebody who also
can't see
uh but you know reality is going to rear
its head
and it may have already done so at least
beginning i mean i'm looking at the
markets the last several days we've seen
some pronounced weakness in the dollar
finally i mean today is one of the
weakest days in several years for the
dollar who knows it might end up being
the weakest day
of several years you know we'll see
gold is starting to a pick up i mean
nothing explosive but we were below 1800
a few days ago now back at 1850-ish
and so even as the stock market is going
down
and
what i am thinking
is that the markets are finally
starting to look beyond
the tightening cycle to the next easing
cycle yes the fed is talking about how
this super strong economy can withstand
higher rates but meantime this super
strong economy is probably already in a
recession
and we're not only just in a recession
we're in a worse recession than what we
call the great request session that we
had following the 2008 financial crisis
and remember
we were six seven eight months into that
recession and they still denied that we
were in one in fact they said there was
no recession anywhere in sight and we
were in the middle of it uh and so i
think they've made the same mistake
again in overestimating the strength of
the economy they think consumers
spending money is economic strength it's
not it's a reflection of inflation and
the economy is actually very weak
beneath the surface but when you look at
the news uh yesterday from target uh
from walmart the day before and now you
know cisco's news today
you can see uh that we're collapsing
into recession that higher prices are
taking a toll as are higher interest
rates on the consumer's ability to keep
on spending uh and unemployment is going
to follow i mean look at uh today
unemployment claims jumped to a
four-month high i think we've already
turned the corner and you know we're
very close to a major spike i think up
in unemployment and so that whole myth
about this strong labor market is going
to die and i think the markets are now
pricing in the fact that the fed is
going to be recognizing that the economy
is not as strong as it thought and it's
going to indicate that it's not going to
raise rates as much or as quickly as it
once believed so when you think about
this let's talk about the idea of of
this recession we also we obviously saw
the q1 uh contraction i think it was
minus 1.4 annualized uh of gdp
do you expect q2 to be contraction as
well and should we expect gdp to
contract through the end of the year is
this like a just get two quarters of it
what is the gdp expectations that you
have through the end of the year let's
start there
well i think it will be another negative
print
so we won't get that until what august
or july july we get the numbers or
something like that but i think there's
a good chance
that we'll get a a negative print i
thought we would there was a good chance
we were going to get a negative print in
q1 very few people believed that and we
ended up getting one
and i think if we avoid one it's
probably because they understated
inflation because they always have to
use a deflator to take the nominal gdp
and make it real but if they're not
using a big enough deflator because
they're understating how much inflation
has pushed up prices then they can kind
of create the illusion that a
contracting economy is growing but i
think you know we're in recession
whether it is officially revealed by the
numbers or not but i think it's it's
going to happen and then you know the
fed's not going to fight inflation when
we're in recession because all the fed's
tough talk about we're going to do
whatever it takes it's all predicated on
this super strong economy and red-hot
labor market that can withstand doing
whatever it takes
powell has never acknowledged his
willingness to continue to fight
inflation if the economy is in a
recession i mean he's been asked that
question but he's never answered it he
always is very evasive and just changes
the topic uh but i i think that if you
you know kind of listen to his praise
for uh paul volcker he is always you
know specific to make sure he has never
praised paul volcker for raising rates
and uh pushing the economy into a
recession to fight inflation he has
always qualified his admiration preval
volcker by saying i admired the fact
that he did what he thought was right
that's all he's willing to give volcker
credit for is doing what he thought was
right now maybe he didn't think that was
right and i think when push comes to
shove when he has to make a decision
between
stimulating the economy because it's in
recession or fighting inflation he will
not make the mistake that paul he will
not make the same choice that paul
volcker made he will make a different
choice because he has a different set of
beliefs yes he thinks inflation's a
problem but not as big a problem as
unemployment and a weak economy and i
think he will
you know ignore the inflation problem
which means it's going to get so much
worse which also means the economy is
going to fare much worse because
inflation is going to decimate it